juste avec un truc vous avez pas eu tout
prix au bristol au pro bowl a tout sauf
de regarder aussi aussi qu'on les
appelle
voulait le bristol non je comprends ce
que les hôtels et tout ça mais c'est
hors de prix très cher à frédéric vous
avez des très bons prix alors moi je
pouvais pas avoir des prix sur du pain
bristol
[Rires]
voilà je j'appelle une papeterie je
voulais te dois d'être minutes à
bristol en revanche le bel faut savoir
que le bristol c'est un des hôtels les
plus chers de paris bien voilà le
best-of ah ouais bah c'est quoi le
plaisir
est plus confiant soyez en lisant il est
peut-être plus confiance aux isa daisy à
vous pensez que je vais appeler
j'appelle de la part des belles mourinho
a fait le fait tout de suite
et tout donner
la naba dans les bombes à bueno aires
par contre j'espère qu'ils vont pas dire
ah bah oui elle est avec roger il ya
deux nuits
là c'est vrai que là ce serait peut-être
un petit peu gênant les sheikh est ce
qu'on peut appeler à faire un numéro en
régie ou pas du tout ah bah non c'est
plus mon oreillette merde
oui en malaisie alors appelé de
l'historien fabrice hall alors est par
contre le bristol l'hôtel 1 parce qu'ils
sont capables d'appeler d'une papeterie
rappelé le bristol à clermont ferrand le
bristol bonjour c'est bondé stabilo
balle mais vous le mettez deux feuilles
de papier qu'on soit merci
voilà merci au revoir oui non non non
dans le bristol on vous me dites quand
c'est bon parce que hacker c'est bon
mathieu va régulièrement j'adore me
henri mathieu no anniversaire au bristol
avait donc cinq concertos qui vous êtes
alors moi ils se souviennent peut-être
ben oui c'est bien parce qu'il ya des
différences nationales il ya deux films
c'était je suis connu
deux minutes après c'est je suis pas sûr
qu'ils soulèvent de moi
je baisse mon devient oui
laisser partir mais bristol ils sont en
train de composer un numéro alors sachez
qu'ils composent avec des bombes
donc c'est pas non plus très évident
voilà un énorme saut comme acteur il
sera lancé
donc a priori ça devrait arriver dans un
instant maurice m'a dit si tu veux tu
peux pas fermer ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
tu vois je sais que tu toi brice mach
rond le président entamée mais ici ici
ici ici c'est un village gaulois je te
le dis ici là mais c'est bon ça les
décès beau expliqué qu'elle était avant
le risque d'y réprimer en fait tu
emmerde tout le monde d'accord que tony
et je sais pas qui est ce maurice vous
risquez tard c'est murray alors s'il
vous plaît ils ont fait le numéro voilà
les mecs ils trouvaient à l amène à
trouver un numéro il répondait vous vous
les appelez vous voulez passer haut la
la la human world in la fois
professionnelle s'il te plaît
appelez là à laleu allô allô
allô
allô c'est leur a fait peur c est qui
c'est des gros
doutes steinbach
tchibo dit battesti louge tellini
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas sûr qu'on est des pros
bristol
uk je ne voulais pas qu'il appelle avec
montel plutôt ici mais make no dig est
un génie merci à l'eau
[Rires]
[Musique]
déjà des jamais su répondre
présente pour les anglais les mecs déjà
là on capte mal vous avez remarqué déjà
le répondeur déjà lyon ratera donc
j'imagine âge et on a aimé en fait cette
émission et qui ne rentre pas sur itunes
est parfois non j'ai l'impression qu'on
passerait giallo
dos les palaces n'attend pas wen
normalement
pas d'interdiction mais on attend on va
les avoir john's a passé sa vie en week
end ils sont dedans qu'on appelle le
rite non messieurs on
va voir à noter aujourd'hui au numéro
suivant les mois c'est quoi un quelqu'un
en direct du risque quoique away arènes
de nîmes pourquoi comment acheter je
suis déjà allé dans des chambres pour
des rendez vous professionnels
rendez vous avec un homme ne pouvait
finalement pas non non jamais le
dépasser pour savoir où tu alors
thomas sirven julien julien mas je vais
l'appeler elle s'appelle julien julien
bobot à
cappelle julien
et ne fait plus rien enrayé vous avez
ces deux penalties assez de mal à cette
émission
à bord vous a été vraiment assez de mal
à cette émission
oui julien
bonsoir oui j'appelle de la part de
guillaume genton
oui bonsoir vous allez bien choïgou oui
très bien en fait je vous appelle parce
que je voudrais
venir en fait j'ai une amie qui est très
très connu chez vous c'est isabelle
morini-bosc vous voyez de qui il s'agit
je suis pas sûr elle vient souvent dans
votre hôtel
jamais
[Rires]
m au soir julien c'est cyril hanouna en
fait on en direct
oui oui oui ça va vous allez bien
merci en tout cas alors qu isabelle
morini-bosc elle vient jamais non mais
non mon avis non messieurs donc c'est
bien ce qui vient va bien aux gens dont
je suis je suis avec lui nous dit qu'ils
seraient un client très assidus
absolument c'est vrai bravo
matthieu delormeau aimerait venir au
bristol voilà
qu'à l'école oui mais il faut qu'ils
appellent le bristol est ce qu'on l'a
non
mais vous êtes vous opposé du bristol un
cachet
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le peuple alors justement plaza athénée
très bel hôtel
bâtonnets map ladakh et bien d'autres
est ce que vous m'avez ce que est ce que
vous avez déjà vu isabelle morini-bosc
au plaza athénée
comptait pas du tout à la pizza athénée
en face
je crois je crois moi vous m'avez jamais
vu mais peut-être vu non
jamais non madame aime ou pas voilà
benjamin est
irréprochable très proche à la main
castaldi il nous dit qu'il vient souvent
non c'est pas vrai
moi j'étais femme les mêmes là dessus
vous êtes mito alors matthieu delormeau
aimerait venir voilà donc on va
certainement vous l'envoyez sachez qu'il
prend énormément d'argent actuellement
dans l'émission
merci juin
les femmes aussi mais de théâtre est bon
et sinon qui trompe c'est pas possible
c'est ça ben ari se trouve dans les
palaces et moi arrive appelé moi-même le
savent ils une fenêtre question comment
s'appelle pour quelles raisons vous avez
ces numéros de téléphone dans votre
téléphone mais si celle ci est
en train de chercher comme un con
oui sur google comme un con là monsieur
a lui-même monsieur hanouna chercher
numéro c'est messi ou quoi parce que tu
as à régis vous êtes est vous êtes vous
êtes en dessous de tout le monde quand
tu les as de tout de tout devient
beaucoup d'hôtels à m'avoir comme client
dans l'accord ils me veulent je veux 50
points quand je les appelle 8,5 en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
battant quelqu'un sinon
vous allez dans laquelle auquel vigan
boulet sont apparus
parce que j'avais déjà fait avec patrick
henry c'est vrai qu'à dsk parfois tu
fais tu fais une escapade à vous les
avez
vous êtes des catastrophiques
c'est quoi ils ne sont pas du tout c'est
un mec qui joue du piano
[Musique]
si vous l'avoir des prix camille j'étais
vous redescendrez l'avant de 2 3 et halo
halo pas maintenant si vous les agresser
allô allô
allô le bristol alors alors le bristol
sur 4 kilomètres d'ici clos
mais les mecs vous voyez pas qu'un
problème
mais n'ont jamais anodine
devient producteur de 6 à 7
c'est bien possible bon il telle finesse
que toi tu as déjà été relogés dans des
hôtels comme ça pour faire acquis face
et l'ouest ont gelé allô
bonjour je viens bristol merci oui oui
bonjour le bristol oui bonjour
j'aimerais avoir une chambre d'appel de
la part d'isabelle morini-bosc
vous voyez qu'il s'agit vous êtes qu'il
s'agit pas du tout
alors oui c'est pas une invention mais
c'est juste avant parce que en fait je
vous explique c'est matthieu delormeau
voiliers qui est matthieu delormeau
voudraient venir résident séjourné au
bristol comme bien sûr pour toute
intimité
et il aimerait savoir si vous faites des
petite ristourne pour les viviers
cuisine mythe ricard
d'accord es-tu pour nous répondre assez
rapidement 50% en fait parce que là
c'est cyril hanouna l'appareil vous
voyez tout de suite
et
je suis avec guillaume genton voyez
c'est ça et qu'une bataille à vannes ou
transférées merci mais je laissais doit
pas vu qu'elle dit oui à tout le monde
voyait qui siège aujourd'hui
mais je vois très bien qui sait le faire
venir pierrick picchi bouchard et qui
vont le sens de l'émission maîtrise très
bien monsieur les petits bouchard de la
mission ouaf ouaf ou
non mais c'est passé voilà ça n'a rien à
voir avec vous ce qu'est ce qu'un nom
mais n'en est pas là s'il est toujours
oui à tout non mais lorsque tu as besoin
d'être dans un palace toi aussi beaucoup
de fous très attendu envie d'aller
là bas
rendez vous avec qui vous êtes pas
célibataire et qui n'attrape pas les
mouches avec du vinaigre ma poule
[Rires]
la crap et déboule sous la halle aux
toiles
oui bonsoir madame je vous appelle de la
part d'isabelle morini-bosc
eric ibouth art
c'est qu'il s'agit avec nick l'équipe
bouchard
l'animateur de nos souffles les enfants
dites moi en fait mathieu delormeau
voudrait séjourné au bristol
avec messi avec le célèbre animateur
maurice bouddha elle
qui anime loiseau et de clown sera art
et
il aimerait ces zones et trois demi avec
lui éventuellement mais voudrait une
ristourne de 50 % est ce possible c'est
maurice il manque photo maurice
boudarène savez l'oiseau de clown cd qui
fait tache coach trek choisi
oui bien sûr alors ils seront tellement
ils auront certainement la visite de
gérer une foule chars
les chroniqueurs sur l'émission tak tak
badaboum voiliers qui sait où est
l'équité
alors c'est tabou qui s'est pas inquiété
par vous qu'il faut casser la
oui bah alors
alors parce qu'on est à l'antenne en
fait c'est sa série la lune à la ccir il
admis mais l'appareil qui je suis
le travail est mauvaise boudarel
arte voilà donc mais vraiment matthieu
delormeau vous menez séjourné au bristol
comme un jour de semaine ont promis de
mettre le cul non non trois nuits pour
un week end ou john junior suite à 50%
vous avez vous demandé cinq ans de saint
mathieu de l'angoissé nombre inouï de
coutume ces normes vont confirmer oui
mais isabelle morini-bosc bien souvent
on voulait pas vu avec gym le futur
vous pas
ces ventes sont très gentils on
rappellera cette dame ne s'est pas
complètement possible non non non c'est
pas mal paru non
non elle était là et elle adore maurice
boudarène très grave et l'oiseau quoi je
sais pas
ce qui m'arrive et konami chaud sur arte
la flûte et
stat qui tue l'afflux une fille ou un
oiseau
j'allais me saute c'est à deux heures de
la soirée
entends-je une flûte ou un oiseau
bleu le rouge gorge ou s ou le rossignol
maurice boudarel